احنا بلدنا 24 منظمه دوليه لبوا نداء
فرنسا واوكرانيا من اجل هذه تعبئه الدوليه
هذا المؤتمر الذي اسميناه متضامننا مع
الشعب الاوكراني ان الكثير من ممثلي
العالمي برمته واكد على هذه النقطه
واشكروا همم رئاسه منظمه ازيان والكمبوديا
وعلى حضورهم
واوروبا والمنظمات الدوليه في مجالات
مختلفه كل هذا يعبر عن همم حماسيه التضامن
العلمي مع اوكرانيا منذ 10 اشهر ان
اوكرانيا تصمود ضد الغزو الروسي
فبراير
بسرعه مفتوحه علينا ان نتذكر بان هذا
الاعتداء قد بدا في الواقع منذ عام 2014
الحرب
بشان العنف العنف القاسي اليوم واريد ان
اشيده هنا بالقوات الروسيه الاوكرانيه
التي صمدت وصدت القوات الروسيه وذلك بفضل
الشجاعتهم وتفنيهم لحمايه اراضيهم اريد ان
اشيد بشعب الاوكراني
ورغم الجرائم المرتكبه من قبل المحتل
الروسيه
ولا سيما في مدن كامري
هذه المدن التي شهدت اثار هذه القسوه هذا
الشعب الاوكراني يستمر في الصمود باراده
لا تلين من اجل بلده وحرياته ان استعاده
كيلسون في منتصف في الشهر نوفمبر
هذا يبين بان الانتخابات
ومن ذلك الوقت همم
استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه الاراضي وهذا
ما يبين ضعف القوات
الروسيه مع كل ارادتها في اركاع الشعب
الاوكراني في كل ارض يتم استعادتها تقوم
روسيا باستهداف المنصات الغازيه او محطه
توزيع المياه التحتيه للطاقه وراثيه ما في
فصل الشتاء وهدفهم واضح هذا فلوسه واضح
اذا كل هزيمه عسكريه هي اثاره الرعب لدى
المدنيين وهذه الضربات التي ستستهدف البنا
التحتيه المدنيه
وروسيا هي تقر بصوره احب ان تريد ان همم
تستهدف وتمس الاراده الاراده اراده
الاوكراني متصوره واضحه وهذا يمس المبادئ
الاساسيه بالحقوق الانسانيه هذه الاعمال
لا تختفر ولا
ينبغي ان تبقى دون عقاب اريد هنا ان اكون
واضحا وفي هذا السياق
ينبغي على اوكرانيا ضحيه هذا الاعتداء ان
يحدد ظروف همم
المفاوضات السلميه وعزيز ان اقتراحاتك في
هذا المجال هي اساس نحن نستطيع البناء
عليها ولكن في الوقت الطارق علينا الان ان
ندعم قدره الشعب الاوكرانيه على الصمود
حتى نسمح لاوكرانيا ان يمر في فصل الشتاء
وبالتالي قمنا بتنظمه
المؤتمرني ونحن نتمنى ان تكون هناك نتائج
ملموسه اولا الامر يتعلق هنا
لزميل
الحلفاء
والمانحين الدوليين من اجل تقديم مساعده
ملموسه ومن اجل المحافظه على البنى
التحتيه الاساسيه ومن اجل دعم صمود السكر
في مجال الطاقه النقل الميه الملابس الى
اخره ونتمنى ان تكون التزاماتنا الجماعيه
على مستوى هذه الرهانات وان نساعدكم على
تلبيه الاحتياجات الملحنه نحن سنقدم
مساعده استثنائيه نحن في فرنسا قمنا
بتقديم 150 فاصله خمسه مليون ونحن سنقدم
اكثر من 40 مليون في هذه السنه في اطار
الاولويات هذا المؤتمر 27 مليون
الشتاء اما تبقى من هذا المبلغ
فيتعلقوا بالصحه النفسيه والمساعده
الاطفال والمساعده الغذائيه بالاضافه لذلك
نحن
مليون
تقدر ب 76 مليون في مجال الطاقه والمبادره
التي تبدا تسويقها مع الفاضيه الاوروبيه
من الجيل الجديد
وايضا سنقوم بتقديم تمويلات فيما يتعلق
بالماء والصحه والمساعده الغذائيه وهذا
الجهد الاضاف في
يقدر ب 125 مليون يورو ك- اا مساعده ملحه
وطاره واشكر كل البلدان على اعلاناتهم
مساعداتهم في هذا المؤتمر ثانيا عزيزيه
همم نحن قلنا تحسين عمليه تنسيق حتى ان
يكون عمليتين وتتوافق هذا المساعدات مع
الاحتياجات الاوكرانيا بالتعاون وزراء
النروج
نريد ان تصل المساعدات بصوره ملموسه
ليكون في فرنسا
نحن بحاجه الى تنسيق عن كتب عن
نقاط اتصال في البلدان حتى تصل هذه
المساعدات بصوره ملموسه ميدانيا اذا
بتعاون مع الاقسام والفرق التابعه
لانفوضيه الاوروبيه ونشكركم على عملهم نحن
نستطيع ان نعلن اليوم ايجاد اليه معززه
للمساعده الدولي
على الاليه المدنيه للاتحاد الاوروبيه
وسيتم توسيعها للاتحاد الاوروبي للبلدان
التي تريد المشاركه في هذا الدعم عدد
بلدان غير اوروبيه حاضره معنا
وقاموا بتعيين نقاط اتصال من اجل العمل في
اطار هذه الاليه هذه البلدان بين الامرهم
لا يتعلق بالوالدين ان غربي حتى نكون على
قناعه بانه ينبغي لدعم اوكرانيا في وقت
طويل اجل اذا انه هذا الامر يتعلق
بالتقديم التعاون الاجل همم الطويل ولا
سيما فيما يتعلق ايضا بالتعاون في مجال
الطاقه في اطار مجموعه السبع وايضا
الاهليه المتعلقه باعاده الاعمار التي تم
توضيعها في تحت الرئاسه الالمانيه لمجموعه
السبع ان هذا المؤتمر وهذه المبادره اليوم
هي تاتي
لتكمل سلسله من الاحداث الدوليه التي
شاهدناها في الاشهر الماضيه والاسيه ما في
ما يتعلق بمؤتمر لوغانو في شهري تموز
يوليو هذا المؤتمر الذي سمح بعمليه اعاده
الاعمار وايجاد المبادئ المتعلقه
اوكرانيه وايضا فيما يتعلق بمؤتمر برلين
في هذا المجال هذا المؤتمر الذي افضل الى
مناقشات مثمره في متعلق بجنسيه اعاده
الاعمار على الاجر الطويل لاوكرانيا وفي
السنه القادمه في لندن سنستمر في هذا
العمل حتى نكون الى جانب اوكرانيا نحن نقف
الاجانب اوكرانيا حتى نعمل وحتى يستمر في
نضاله من اجل الحريه وان فرنسا تريد ان
تطلع بدورها في متعلق باعاده الاعمار وبعد
ظهر اليوم معك السيد رئيس الوزراء سنحضره
منتدى اقتصاديا بحضور اكثر من 700 شركه
ومؤسسه من اجل العمل لتلبيه الاحتياجات
والاستثمارات دوله في اوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى هذا العمل اريد ان اشكر
تعبير وحشت كل النظمات والمجتمع الفرنسيه
بحضور الرئيس همم
وزيره الخارجيه كلنا هناك كثير من هنا همم
فيما يتعلقوا باستقبال
اللاجئين وتم تقديم 9.5 مليون يورو
كمساعدات
المساعدات العاجله لفصل الشتاء وايضا فيما
يتعلق بالجمعيه الوطنيه
الشيوخ والكثير من الاساساتهم حاضرون معنا
في هذه
القاعه اذا كل الفريق الفريق الفرنسي اذا
جاز تعبير هم حاضرون هنا في هذا المجال
اذا بالاضافه اذا التزامات اليوم هناك دعم
يوميا وملموس وانا اشكرهم على كل هذه
الجهود هذا ما اردته ان اقوله في افتتاح
هذا المؤتمر عزيزي
واريد هنا ان نقول لك بانك انت ترى اليوم
ما في باريس رؤساء الدول
وزراء الى جانبي العاقلتيك ورئيس الوزراء
كلهم يريدون ان يعملوا وينادوا الاجانب
الشعب الاوكراني وحتى اخر يوم واخر دقيقه
ان لن نتنازل عن اي شيء بشان هذا التضامن
لان النضال الذي تاخذنه من اجل الحريه من
اجل سيادتكم وهو ايضا نضال من اجل النظام
الدولي ومن اجل استقرارنا جميعا عزيزي
افلامير
كل شرف ان اعطي الكلمه لك تفضل